les femmes auraient de meilleures
prédispositions que les hommes pour être
astronaute ce sont les conclusions d'une
étude réalisée par la NASA en 1950 mais
à l'époque ce rapport a été
volontairement caché par le gouvernement
américain plus légère elle nécessite
moins de carburant au décollage plus
petites elles ont également besoin de
moins d'oxygène si l'on en croit une
étude récente les femmes auraient
également plus de chances de survivre à
une crise cardiaque si cela arrivait et
leur appareil reproducteur serait moins
vulnérable aux rayons cosmique que celui
des hommes enfin des expériences menées
en milieu confinés dans des cuves à eau
avec privation sensorielle ont montré
que les femmes s'adaptent mieux que les
hommes aux espaces exigus et quelle
résistent mieux à l'isolement prolongée
pourtant depuis 60 ans seulement
67 astronautes sur plus de 600 étaient
des femmes elles ne représente que 15%
des personnes qui sont allées dans
l'espace